[Musique]
et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Charles du boulot bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes
guidée haute montagne et alpinistes et
vous avez au mois de janvier dernier
réalisé un exploit l'ascension en
solitaire et en hiver de la face nord
des grandes Jorah c'est dans le massif
du Mont-Blanc c'est l'un des itinéraires
les plus extrêmes des Alpes et de cette
ascension vous avez fait un film qui
s'appelle de l'ombre à la lumière et
heureusement pour les spectateurs ce
film commence par la fin
c'est pas six jours c'est 32 ans de
partage pour en arriver là
celui qui filme ce grand moment
d'émotion Charles du boulot c'est
Sébastien Montaz Rousset qui est monté
par l'autre versant des grands jurasses
pour vous retrouver au sommet vous venez
à ce moment-là de vivre six jours et 5
nuits à la fois d'enfer et de paradis
alors ouais en tant qu'alpiniste on peut
pas vraiment parler d'enfer parce que
finalement c'est un peu ce qu'on
recherche en revanche c'est sûr que les
conditions de d'ascension dans ces
phases là en plein hiver au mois de
janvier elles sont très très rustiques
donc
ça demande bah voilà de bien s'adapter à
ce milieu de bien le connaître et pour
moi faire ce genre d'ascension qui est
l'une des voix les plus dures en fait
des Alpes en escalade et en mix donc en
glace et ben c'est aller toucher un
petit peu le sommet de ma pratique le
sommet de mon art donc donc c'est sûr
qu'en haut on voit en larmes mais en
fait c'est quand même des larmes un
petit peu de bonheur et de soulagement
mais il faut juste aussi s'imaginer
quelque chose c'est toujours un peu
difficile vous expliquer là sur un
plateau mais c'est que je viens de
passer vraiment six jours pendus dans
mon baudrier dans une phase Nord si on
voit le soleil et puis tout simplement
là j'arrive au sommet d'une d'une
calotte neigeuse où il y a du soleil ou
ses places ça devient beaucoup plus
hospitalier et même si on a même si j'ai
vraiment l'habitude de ce genre de
milieu et ben voilà c'est les le bonheur
ouais vous dites que c'est un petit peu
rustique pour qu'on comprenne bien de
quoi on parle les grandes jorats c'est
une muraille de pierre et de glace c'est
une paroi verticale altitude 4200 8
mètres la voix que vous avez emprunté
s'appelle Rolling Stones effectivement
vous n'avez pas vu le soleil pendant 6
jours non seulement vous êtes dans
l'ombre donc mais il fait -30 qu'est-ce
qui fait qu'on se lance dans un projet
pareil et pourquoi est-ce que vous
vouliez le faire tout seul alors on se
lance dans un dans un projet pareil
quand on a vraiment on va dire un
objectif de de performance en tout cas
moi dans dans ma pratique d'alpinisme
les grandes jorats c'est un terrain
d'expression il faut savoir qu'il y a
trois grandes faces noires dans les
Alpes donc il y a la lors du Cervin la
face nord de lager et la face nord des
grandes joras qui ont longtemps été en
fait dans les Alpes les faces nord comme
un vaincu très très compliqué à grimper
et puis à travers ces à traverser
face-à-être différents itinéraires et
Rolling Stones l'itinéraire que j'ai
gravite et sans doute l'un des plus durs
en fait de cette phase là donc donc
voilà il y a sans doute une forme de
défi aussi de vouloir aller grimper ça
en hiver et puis il y a les sols pour
moi bah comme je l'ai dit un petit peu
tout à l'heure ça c'est vraiment on va
dire un peu le sommet de mon arme ma
pratique de tout ça parce que il faut
tout gérer tout seul il y a un
engagement vraiment supplémentaire
mentalement c'est aussi beaucoup plus
compliqué et voilà il faut il faut
savoir se faire confiance avancer ce
convaincre des bons choix il y a
beaucoup de prise de décision ça rend
pas compte souvent quand on est encore
des quand on est à deux et on prend une
décision on se consulte et en fait quand
on est seul et ben c'est sans arrêt seul
qu'il faut soit se persuader soit soit
se dire non là tu as pas pris le bon
choix revenir en arrière pour la petite
histoire elle s'appelle Rolling Stones
cette voix parce que il y a eu des
chutes de pierre voilà exactement alors
vous êtes seul par définition donc vous
parlez beaucoup tout seul parce que vous
vous filmez pour pour réaliser ce film
vous chantez aussi beaucoup vous passez
par toutes les émotions le rire les
larmes et vous répétez trois choses
d'ailleurs on l'a entendu à l'instant
dans ce que vous disiez en arrivant au
sommet c'est métal alors expliquez-nous
ce que ça voulait dire c'est beau et
j'ai peur alors métal c'est une
expression un peu qu'on a c'est vraiment
propre à notre microcosme d'alpiniste
mais métal ça veut dire que c'est
qu'on est dans le dur puis que c'est un
peu engagé enfin que c'est un peu risqué
quoi donc ça c'est l'expression métal et
que j'utilise beaucoup trop d'ailleurs
enfin vu que je me suis filmé comme je
le fais généralement lors des ascensions
je me suis pas dit que que le
réalisateur c'est le montage il allait
reprendre à chaque fois ce mot-là et en
fait finalement je le dis quand même
beaucoup ça doit être un tic de langage
et vous extasiez beaucoup du paysage et
je m'exasis beaucoup du paysage ouais
parce qu'en fait alors moi je suis pas
quelqu'un de contemplatif je m'arrête
pas 15 minutes devant devant un paysage
pour me dire waouh c'est beau en
revanche je suis dans ce milieu en
permanence et à chaque fois je trouve
tout ce que je trouve qui m'entend je
suis très heureux d'être là et je trouve
ça incroyable donc c'est vrai que je le
dis souvent et vous dites que vous avez
peur aussi et ça ça je dis que j'ai peur
et en fait j'ai en montagne moi j'ai
toujours peur enfin j'ai quasiment alors
ça dépend dans le genre de phase j'ai
quand même toujours peur et c'est pas la
peur qui va me faire faire demi-tour et
qui va faire que je vais rentrer chez
moi c'est plutôt une peur qui va
permettre d'éveiller tous mes sens et de
rester très concentré pendant 6 jours et
en fait c'est ouais cette petite peur
qui vient affuter un peu mon regard être
enfin moi ressentir peut-être le froid
la douleur tout ça parce que quand on a
un peu peur ben on est un peu plus
stimulé et j'ai pas de problème à le
dire en fait c'est extraordinairement
physique vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
parce que le fait d'être tout seul
rajoute quelque chose de supplémentaire
c'est que vous devez faire plusieurs
fois l'ascension en réalité exactement
en fait voilà quand on alors quand on
grimpe généralement même encore des dans
des grandes phases comme ça on a le
pénis mon progresse par des portions de
40 ou 50 m et on est deux il y a le
premier grimpe le deuxième le rejoint ça
se passe comme ça et quand on est seul
et ben il faut grimper redescendre
chercher les affaires en bas et
récupérer son matériel remonter donc ça
fait faire à peu près trois fois
l'ascension voilà
l'exploit plus plus alors au sixième
jour de l'Ascension dans les dernières
heures vous craquez et vous faites
plusieurs longueurs ça s'appelle en solo
intégral qui est une discipline dans la
discipline c'est-à-dire sans corde avec
votre sac à dos qui pèse quoi une
trentaine de kilos c'est ça et là vous
vous entendez dans le film vous parlez à
votre femme qui n'est pas là il
s'appelle Fanny et qui vous lui dites
promis Fanny je vais pas tomber parce
que là chaque pas un pas pas au bon
endroit
alors là c'est le solo intégral j'en
utilise pas trop dans cette dans ce
genre de voix parce que
1200 mètres du sol donc voilà donc en
fait j'en abuse pas trop tout simplement
parce que quand j'y vais en solo
intégral à la fin c'est que déjà c'est
un petit peu plus facile les ce que je
vais grimper est plus facile que ce que
j'ai grimpé avant ça me permet d'y aller
en sol intégrale c'est vrai que ça avait
été au début de l'ascension je serais
peut-être pas aller dans ce mode de
progression mais là j'en avais marre je
voulais sortir et puis après une fois de
plus ça peut paraître un peu fou un peu
mais voilà je suis faire entraîner je
sais vraiment dans quoi je m'engage même
si ça rajoute forcément une dose
d'engagement mais j'essaye de maîtriser
à peu près tous les paramètres alors ça
pose bien sûr et on vous la pose souvent
cette question des risques que vous
prenez vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
vous êtes jeune papa vous avez une
petite fille vous dites qu'après cette
ascension vous n'avez à la fois jamais
eu autant envie de vivre et pourtant
vous continuez il y a un moment assez
fort dans le film où vous dites que un
de vos copains vous dit vous dit que un
jour vous allez vous tuer ouais bah
c'est sûr en fait c'est c'est mine de
rien c'est ça nous le rappelle assez
souvent malheureusement parce qu'on perd
beaucoup de copains en montagne et je
parle un peu au nom des des alpinistes
des guides c'est sévéra c'est vraiment
une réalité ça fait partie de notre
milieu et moi j'ai pas envie de de de
concevoir ma pratique en fermant les
yeux et en me disant que ça peut pas
arriver donc je préfère être lucide
là-dessus dire les choses et de toute
façon c'est comme ça qu'elle se passe et
dans le genre d'ascension alors
l'objectif c'est absolument pas de de
pas rentrer chez soi bien au contraire
c'est de réussir c'est de c'est d'aller
chercher un peu ce qu'on nous les
alpinistes on peut on peut chercher dans
ces phases là mais y aller en se disant
c'est sûr que tout va bien se passer et
que je vais rentrer ça paraîtrait très
prétentieux et moi je préfère me dire
non non j'ai conscience de marcher sur
un fil maintenant à moi d'être le plus
équilibré d'essayer de toujours une
question de décision en fait de prendre
les bons décisions bon moment de faire
des choix le grand alpiniste Stéphane
Ross qui est décédé en montagne en 2012
et qui était l'un de vos mentor le film
d'ailleurs lui est dédié dit que la
liberté précisément cette choisisse de
choisir son itinéraire dans la vie comme
en montagne qu'être libre c'est choisir
et ça c'est c'est un luxe auquel vous
êtes attaché c'est exactement un luxe
auquel je suis attaché et c'est d'autant
plus pour ça que j'aime l'alpinisme
parce que l'alpinisme c'est vraiment un
terrain d'expression très très libre on
est il y a vraiment pas de règles on
peut faire ce qu'on veut on l'a toujours
vu à travers le temps les alpinistes ont
on fait des choses qui peuvent paraître
complètement déraisonnable juste par
simple passion mais c'est ce qu'on fait
donc oui effectivement être libre c'est
pouvoir choisir choisir c'est renoncer
aussi il y a quelques semaines au Népal
je crois que vous ça fait demi-tour on
était on est resté deux mois on devait
grimper un pilier ouest donc couvrir une
nouvelle voix un nouvel itinéraire dans
le pilier ouest du manage Luc et un
sommet qui monte à 8000 mètres et il y a
eu une mousson très forte il y a eu
énormément de neige et on n'a pas pu on
n'a pas pu faire ce qu'on projetait de
faire on a même pas pu essayer en fait
en raison des conditions il y avait
beaucoup de monde aussi et ça c'est
peut-être quelque chose à l'échelle de
votre Vidal pénis que vous avez vu
changer au cours du temps et qui
peut-être change un peu la pratique oui
c'est sûr que alors nous ce qu'on fait
il faut c'est complètement différent du
monde qu'on peut voir sur une voie
normale d'un gros sommet d'une montagne
nous on va ouvrir un itinéraire juste
avec nos propres moyens ce qu'on appelle
le ciel peint c'est vraiment l'alpinisme
sur les autres versions de montagne ce
qu'on peut voir moi j'appellerai plutôt
ça des marcheurs d'altitude donc des
gens qui connaissent très peu la
montagne finalement qui sont venus là
parce que parce que finalement bah ils
ont ils ont payé puis ils ont quand même
le rêve d'y aller hein je je crie pas
par exemple les images de bouchons en
haut de l'Everest et c'est exactement ça
et en fait on se retrouve dans des
situations où tout le monde va au sommet
au même moment par un itinéraire très
précis très EMP voilà ça fait des
problèmes de un peu de surpopulation
vous êtes aussi Charles duboulleuse le
témoin malheureux du réchauffement
climatique vous avez dit il y a quelques
temps que la montagne a été cet été
d'une tristesse remarquable ça aussi
depuis que vous commencez à depuis que
vous pratiquez une vingtaine d'années
vous l'avez vu changer à même à durer là
ouais c'est considérable et j'irai même
que sur les trois quatre dernières
saisons d'été qu'on a eu le changement
en montagne tel que nous on la pratique
il est vraiment radicale et cet été on a
eu un un espèce d'emballement où on se
dit toujours ah ça va cet été où on se
projette toujours pour l'été prochain ou
l'hiver prochain non ça ira mieux il va
neigera des précipitations et non
c'était il y a fait vraiment très sec
très chaud et surtout il y a eu très peu
de précipitations c'est à dire que une
fois que la glace est attaquée qui que
la neige ne retombe pas dessus comme
c'est le cas normalement l'été et ben ça
attaque on va dire la structure la
matière première et puis finalement ça
fond à une vitesse assez incroyable donc
la montagne a énormément changé même par
rapport à la génération d'alpinistes
d'avant et je pense que que dans les
années à venir ça va continuer de
s'accélérer
la pratique de votre sport alors moi sur
ma pratique ça ça impacte quand même
beaucoup de choses ça veut dire qu'il y
a beaucoup de voix ou d'itinéraire qui
sont plus envisageables tout simplement
parce que en fait il faut se rendre
compte que dans les parois qu'on grimpe
le la roche généralement et tenu par la
glace et en fait quand cette glace se
réchauffe et ben les pierres viennent
tomber le rocher est moins bon et on
peut tout simplement plus y aller donc
ça ça change vraiment et puis tout
simplement les glaciers fondent plus
donc
plus loin alors il faut aller soit plus
loin soit plus haut mais même en tant
que guide haute montagne quand on est
avec quand on est avec nos clients il y
a des il y a des courses en montagne qui
devaient être faciles un peu dans la
neige maintenant sont dans la glace sont
beaucoup plus difficiles donc voilà le
terrain il évolue constamment à nous
nous adapter de toute façon on pourra
pas faire de grands changements du du
jour au lendemain ça on a bien
conscience donc nous on essaye de
s'adapter au mieux pour pour continuer
d'évoluer dans ce milieu qu'on aime bon
sur le plus court terme il y a des beaux
projets j'imagine pour l'hiver qui
commence et oui oui il y a des projets
alors j'ai rien de très défini mais j'ai
quand même pas mal de choses en tête je
serais assez opportuniste pour son
fonction des conditions météo et des
conditions voilà si vous voulez voir ce
que c'est qu'un exploit de l'ombre à la
lumière sera présenté à montagne en
scène qui est un festival très chouette
qui a lieu ici à Paris au Grand Rex du 9
au 12 décembre prochain merci infiniment
merci Charles du boulot d'être venu ce
matin sur ce plateau bon retour dans
cette nouvelle région de Haute-Savoie et
voilà et belle hiver à vous belle-sœur
nous on se retrouve juste après la pause
avec Damien coquet à tout de suite
[Musique]